welcome to the start of the great
Germany scootering I want to cross all
over Germany from north to south jump on
this cooler 2473 kilometers in just 80
days it's a major challenge and I'm sure
I'll endure my fair share of pain and
suffering on this journey because
scooters like this are slow i'll be able
to experience germany and german culture
in all of its glorious detail and won't
miss a thing along the way starting at
germany's northernmost point on the
island of zills and on the trip I'll be
crossing the states of
schleswig-holstein lower saxony
saxony-anhalt and chilean outside
frankfurt all had a little more west
through botton Breton bag and into
bavaria where after 80 days i hope to
reach the country southernmost point the
haledon vaanga Eck I'll and I'll be
clocking up all those kilometres and
believe me a whole lot is going to
happen along the way it cold what do you
think and I take this scooter all the
way across Germany 2473 kilometers of
course you can you've got a lot on your
plate though yeah how do I make it or
not yeah why cuz you're in good shape ok
ok you've got the right attitude mine
you've got my blessing I looked at so
just what I wanted to hear lots of
encouragement when people believe in you
it helps get things rolling got to be
careful not to get cocky though even
though I've prepared for this in a big
way I've cut out the cigarettes and
booze been eating organic food and
clocked around 200 kilometers of running
and around 300 more on the scooter
of course you need the right equipment
to cross Germany on a scooter so my
vehicle tests tires with a diameter of
30 and 40 centimeters it has front and
rear brakes front and rear lights it has
a special horn and it has a real Bureau
to see everything behind me and then
there's this nifty navigation device
it'll bring me safely down the right
bike paths to my destination this
odometer will tell me how far I've come
and that RV there's my support vehicle
that's messed you Liam ish she'll be
driving it down the highways and byways
time to head for the starting line the
tip of what's called the elbow on zil's
this is the largest German island in the
North Sea just under a hundred square
kilometers I'm standing here at the
northernmost point of Germany the
Olympic sprint in the middle of a nature
preserve it's only four kilometers to
the mainland but that would be on the
Danish instead of the German side
between me and my destination the
southernmost point in Germany lie an
unimaginable two and a half thousand
kilometers an emotional moment let's do
it a little anti-climactic hmm my
scooter isn't very good in sand
as I head south on the first leg of my
journey I really noticed that a lot of
the old houses here have been perfectly
restored with eight hundred fifty
thousand visitors a year silt is a
magnet for tourists but also a favorite
destination for the country's super-rich
and the price is here reflective homes
can change hands for astronomical sums
up to 35 thousand euros per square meter
plenty of impressions on the first day
out as I head over the causeway to the
mainland our RV has been put on the
train the only way to get it off the
island since I can't go over the
causeway on my scooter I decided to do
this as a compromise folks the first day
was great I feel like I master the
challenge easily so far 24 of the 2473
kilometers are behind me pretty much one
percent
you